so do you feel like you're having a
moment right now between because you've
got some pretty cool upcoming stuff in
the future and this you sort of feel
like you won the actors lottery I think
you're doing okay I have to ask you I'm
a big fan of Michael Bay I'm a big fan
of Netflix I know we're at an Amazon
event the hell was it like filming oh
you're gonna be you're gonna you're
gonna be fine you've already wrapped him
the check is cleared what was it like
working with him on six underground I
would have warned me about him
I absolutely love it
talk a little bit on who you play in the
film if you can I think yeah and like on
who you okay well go on to something
else something that we're used you've
entered the Sony spider-man universe and
you got to work with chair and a Fortius
so this one I'm talking about the actors
lottery what what can you say about that
because venom was his huge
the interesting part about get to kind
of introduce
world and and I think that's I think
that people are really gonna like one of
the things that I like about Jared is he
always goes for it
he's like he's just a really really
talented actor talk a little bit about
getting to like work with him and maybe
what you took away from the experience
[Music]
[Music]
yet the other thing is talk a little bit
but when you sign on for something like
that oh sure
talk a little bit about when you're
signing on to these kind of projects how
nervous are you like the day before your
first meeting going in to meet with like
Jared or going in to read with Michael
and to talk about these projects like
you know what I mean
[Music]
the movie itself I do my work but I I go
in in the world I'm gonna go for it but
with nature I think you're in the first
view of every single don't you know
Congrats on this you got to talk to more
people